oh
[Music]
what is the worst anime ever made now
some of you newer fans May scroll down
to the lowest rated anime on my anime
list and point out some shows that have
gone down in infamy that have been
clowned on by the entire anime Community
like Mars of Destruction or scale to
heaven or seven deadly sins but go
further back and a handful of you may
remember that years ago one anime rose
up the ranks to gain an almost legendary
status like the planets had aligned in
all the wrong ways to create a stinker
so bad so foul Christopher Nolan's about
to make a three-hour biopic and up at
this pond
this was a [__] roach that derailed a
train that smashed into a nuclear power
plant that caused the Fallout that could
rival Chernobyl this garnered the
reputation of being the worst anime ever
made a show so bad it loops around to
become a masterpiece so in the current
generation of Twitter people calling
Demon Slayer mid or threatening to
commit acts of violence over a single
frame of dodgy looking CG in Attack on
Titan I thought it was time I
experienced the show myself so we can
all be reminded just how bad bad can be
this is the legend of gazi's wing
wow
[Applause]
Grandma why did you make hot noodles on
such a hot day but before we get into
this forgotten Masterpiece of a stinker
a word from our sponsor reverse 1999
reverse 1999 is a 20th century strategic
RPG developed by Blue POC games set to
launch on mobile and PC platforms on
October 26th pre-register now to get
your free five-star character in this
game you'll take a trip back to the 20th
century and if you didn't hear me before
the game launches globally October 26th
and by pre-registering you get a starter
countdown to the pass and get a free 5
Star character that speaks in a cute
French accent the nature
day of the year 1999 and the flow of
time has started to become unstable in a
world where Natural Born spellcasters
exist called arcanists history starts
flowing backwards during a catastrophic
phenomenon known as the storm as the
timekeeper named verton it's your job to
seek the truth about this storm and the
Mysterious circumstances surrounding it
before the turn of the New Millennium
wibbly wobbly timey wimey stuff sounds
pretty epic right well blue pop games
have managed to give such a large story
spanning centuries in a gorgeous little
package in order to make you feel like
you're traveling through history we get
a blend of various retro art styles from
pop art to classical oil paintings but
that only scratches the surface that
diverse presentation also carries over
to the voice acting with a diverse cast
of actors with British Italian French
and other accents pair these with an
emotionally gripping story and what
you're left with is a game that fills me
with nothing but excitement did I
mention you can summon a UFO that
abducted a cow so what are you waiting
for pre-register today to get your free
Wi-Fi by clicking that link in the
description and make sure you follow
reverse 1999 on all their social
channels while you're down there thank
you very much to reverse 1999 for
sponsoring us today and with that said
back together
thank you gazi's Wing is a three episode
OVA from 1996 but to Garner such a
reputation like the worst anime ever
made the show must have done something
pretty bad to leave such a deep
impression on so many people what
atrocities lie in this anime what sin
must this show have committed to build
such a stat
I can never Escape can I the story
follows our protagonist a Japanese man
going by the name of Chris Paving the
way as the template for future isakai
protagonists a guy of indomitable
strength and power a true main character
forgotten in the annuals of time a man
of true Charisma and unmatched Riz hey
Chris hi you should look good for
someone preparing for an exam you
certainly got sexy we joined Chris as
he's getting scolded by a female friend
for some reason but Chris has got no
time for this because he's going home to
attend his class reunion pool party I
will come back after I attend the class
reunion pool party but on his way home
his necklace starts vibrating and has a
strange reaction to a shrine before he
is whisked away by a trans-dimensional
space duck and wait hold on a sec
yeah that's definitely a real sentence I
just wrote down but who is Chris why is
this girl angry at him will he make it
to the class reunion pool party why is
there a trans-dimensional space duck
does his helmet say anal all questions
the series has deemed irrelevant as all
this happens within the first one minute
and 30 seconds of run time what what is
going on some may call this bad writing
and pacing but clearly gazi's Wing was
truly ahead of its time wasting no
screen time and isikai and its
protagonists thrusting him head first
into a fantasy world naked in a violent
battle where a group of rebels are
revolting against their Kingdom at War
against
being slaves
yes this may be a forgotten show from
1996 but no matter what time period of
History we're in if there are three
things that are certain in life it's
death taxes and izakai Anime having
slavery but hold on guys because this
time our protagonist is here to end
slavery rather than partaking it because
apparently he is meant to be a holy
Warrior prophesies to turn the tides of
War that the rebels immediately
recognize oh my gosh that skill is he
the holy Warrior
[Music]
thank you
see even though he's just an ordinary
guy Chris tries to live up to become the
holy Warrior they say he is he may have
unwillingly be put into a war he knew
nothing about but seeing this group of
truly oppressed people used and abused
slaves having to fight for dear life
every day just to survive while torn
away from their friends families and
loved ones Chris being the good guy that
he is quickly empathizes with the
struggles they are going through oh I'm
sorry please stop crying huh if you
didn't fly out I would still be in
costanga Hill playing with my friends
and Grandma Malai
I could also have attended my High
School class reunion
but like Batman and the Joker guts and
griffith good food takes in me every
good protagonist needs an equally great
antagonist and luckily gazi's Wing
provides just that with a threatening
the intimidating the Sinister uh uh
a general seen here making his epic
entrance working with the King to
prevent the Rebellion that horses commit
die to prevent the rebellion and Chris
from succeeding at all costs and it's up
to Chris to use his intelligence
correctly using his Advanced Knowledge
from the modern world to out think
outsmart his opponents using the tools
he has available in innovative ways to
save the tribe from their fate thanks to
his Superior intellect it will blow up
don't bother me
are you covering covering that and gotta
powder well yes I'm trying to
doesn't work so hey this looks like a
simple Easter car where a normal guy
gets transported to another world
becomes some legendary hero Saves the
World I've seen this before nothing new
here wrong because the thing is when the
trans-dimensional space Dart transported
him over it also left a copy of his real
body in his original World and thanks to
his necklace having some kind of
telepathic link so waking up with an
aching body and bruises everywhere Chris
has a hard job explaining to himself
bruised all over my party because I had
to fight naked exactly what kind of
situation he's in right now there is a
war going on even dinosaurs are here and
they use bows and arrows my sword is
unbelievably dull [__] Chris man
you're gonna kill yourself and me many
credit the popularization of the modern
isekai genre to Sword Art online with a
gimmick of being stuck in a game where
if you die in the game you die in real
life but now I can see that gazi's Wing
was actually the true progenitor of this
as the characters themselves realize
just how high the stakes are
we are still one person we die together
probably
no it can't be true I'm not joking and
the worst thing about this is is that
this is unironically an interesting
concept having an older ego stuck in
both a fantasy world and the real world
where they can communicate with each
other is a concept I haven't seen any
modern isekai tackle don't quote me on
that there's probably Anita car I'm
forgetting and since they're both shared
damage and fatigue that means the stakes
are real real world Chris might not be
fighting any battles but he could still
die at any time since the Chris in the
real world is stuck on the sidelines he
has the opportunity to provide something
even more valuable than man I'm going to
the class reunion at the community pool
I think it will be good for my present
mental condition oh he didn't
what's the full party
how to prioritize the right things in
life take a page out of Chris's book
from least to most important we have
eating not dying ending slavery class
reunion pool party are you in danger now
Chris
I have no choice but to see my friends
now I've been hearing some slanderous
claims that the huge dub voice acting is
some of the worst that's ever been heard
I take this personally what are don't
mind and the other people doing they're
The Suicide Squad sure everyone may
speak like they sound like they forgot
they have caps lock on word emphasis all
over the place but are you telling me a
bad duck can have voice actors that can
deliver the line
so perfectly every single time
[Music]
a name so powerful it can invoke enough
different emotions from our protagonist
to rival any oscar-worthy performance
confusion
what desperation why can't you do
something for us Mr Yamato takes despair
what is this legendary Yamato takuru no
Mikoto well it's something relevant to
the plot I don't I don't know they never
explain why you keep saying it that
makes sense and honestly how else is
such Shakespearean level writing meant
to be delivered like the line just a
human humans are just human humans are
just human could this be referring to
Mankind's struggle against themselves
that no matter how much we struggle or
fight against it there is no going
against our own nature clearly this line
was so influential it laid the
foundation for the Shiro Emir School of
philosophy it's what we call a drug in
my world if you taste it or smoke it you
get happy and do crazy things
she definitely hits the blood look at
her she's ready to smoke a fat one right
now not also forgetting that one very
important aspect when it comes to anime
is appeal in order to be successful you
can increase your chances by appealing
to as wide of an audience as you can no
matter the age range and gazi's Wing did
something truly revolutionary by
speaking in a language that could be
understood by toddlers who have yet to
achieve object permanence it is most
effective to place a durag roll at gabou
Juju if you bar off the ruggle roll we
are entering
you may be looking at clips of this and
thinking gig up this is an old anime why
would I want to go back and watch
something that looks so old and you know
I understand the sentiment as the anime
industry evolves you get to see the
average quality of Animation improving
with new tools new talent in general
anime has never looked better but even
with all these developments there are
still many that argue that hand-drawn
cell animation can look just as good and
after seeing gazi's Wing I'm inclined to
agree sure we may have our demon Slayers
or chainsaw mans now but what I didn't
realize is that action animation may
have already peaked 30 years ago
this is the bar modern animators have
been chasing all along
now you may be wondering what kind of
person would be behind such a project
perhaps some random nobody that never
worked on anime again someone who had no
knowledge of the industry close because
this was actually the brainchild of
yoshiyuki tomino The Mastermind behind
such other anime projects like Mobile
Suit Gundam
oh yeah
I must somehow make sense of our
convoluted situation gazi's Wing isn't
short a masterpiece of garbage there may
be anime that are worth looking there
may be anime that are technically lower
rated but no other show has quite come
together in the completely wrong ways to
result in such an entertainingly
horrible product we've had some horrible
stinkers in the modern day but time
won't forget the mythical Adventures of
Japanese man Chris and the legend that
is
gazi's wing whatever the hell guys
what was that was that ever explained
what the [__] was half the plot of the
show in the end
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
occasions